ouais ça vient de lancer une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui vous permet de
verrouiller chaque conversation
individuellement alors je vous explique
pourquoi en fait si vous avez un
smartphone qui peut passer entre
différentes mains que vous ne voulez pas
que certaines conversations soient
visibles et bien vous pouvez définir que
chaque conversation individuellement
vous choisissez celle que vous voulez et
bien ne soit pas visible par des tierces
personnes pour l'avoir il va falloir
aller dans les conversations qui sont
bloquées s'appelle chat loc et vous
allez le déverrouiller soit avec votre
capteur d'empreinte digitale soit avec
facite directement sur un iPhone et
autre point qui est intéressant lorsque
vous recevez une notification et bien ça
vous marque un nouveau message de reçu
vous ne savez pas qui vous l'envoyez
vous ne voyez pas le contenu du message
donc si vous avez des choses à cacher ou
si vous avez un smartphone ou plusieurs
personnes peuvent potentiellement venir
utiliser et que vous voulez venir cacher
certaines conversations et bien vous le
faites grâce à chat club pour l'activer
c'est très simple vous allez sur
WhatsApp pour la fiche du contact pour
lesquelles vous voulez venir cacher vos
conversations vous descendez et en
dessous de messages éphémère vous avez
chat Lock vous cliquez dessus et vous
venez l'activer pour les conversations
avec cette personne